um
as this happens to a lot of my clients
which happened to me a lot of people
from my previous life my past life is
like Bro you've changed I remember you
used to be like this yeah right you had
an incident happen with a previous
friend where she made some public
comments about you uh you can go into
what those comments were but how did
that affect you and like how were you
able to deal with that uh yeah that was
I was very surprised that she did that
to be honest
um well she actually I stopped being
friends with her like a a while ago so
this wasn't like recent
um and what happened was I was making
some comments about fat chicks and I was
talking about how you shouldn't and I
think this is basic like we shouldn't
gain a bunch of weight after you get
married yeah like I think that's kind of
like not being a good wife she had
gained a bunch of weight I hadn't seen
her in a while it wasn't about her but
the thing was like she kept like trying
to get me to like every time she'd watch
my show and just be like oh you can't
say that you can't like because she was
kind of feminist and
um like and I was always fine like that
was kind of outside of our friendship
you know
um and we just you know before you could
just like talk about other stuff once
you go online like your friends see all
your opinions and yeah and so she said
she wanted to stop being my friends and
it was weird because when I said okay
fine like you you said this and then she
got like really mad and what I realized
is like women can kind of be like
spiteful and the problem is like with
girls is though they'll kind of like
take a half truth and kind of been I
don't even I don't even remember what
she said to be honest I just remember
being like well that wasn't really true
you know I just remember like watching
it and thinking but what I realized is
like
I can't really control people and
um yeah that was it was sad but because
I was friends with her for like 20 years
one of the issues is that she went
public with it and started making
content based on your relationship with
her like showing old photos and stuff
like that oh I didn't do that no she did
yes she did yeah that's what I'm talking
about yeah it's very it reminds me very
similar of like a horrible situation
with uh Justin Waller's Mom I don't know
if you've ever seen this thing but just
as long as Mom starts like saying stuff
that like clearly wasn't true yeah about
Justin and I thought it was so low brow
of like certain somebody to interview
her when that whole thing happened but
it's one of these things where it's like
you're not a content creator but all of
a sudden you're trying to become famous
off this thing yeah well and yeah she
was like oh she's never had a boyfriend
but I'm like what are you talking about
I just have I don't know so I was like
what I don't know she was kind of nutty
yeah but um I wasn't like crazy shocked
because I I don't know it was kind of a
weird thing with her where I always felt
like
um how do I put it like I felt like we
were like closer when we were younger
and like I don't know if you've ever had
someone like from high school where you
like your life just kind of gets like
better and there's like doesn't so they
kind of like Get out of shape I kind of
I have 20 or 30 friends that went to
jail for selling crack cocaine oh gosh
okay well she wasn't that bad
but but it was it's just like I just
feel like her life wasn't really like
going the way it wanted and I kind of
felt this kind of drifting apart like a
couple years earlier and it's kind of a
weird thing with women where you can
kind of feel like I'm getting kind of
like jealous of you because you know
I'm trying not to like say too much but
I felt like like she was always like my
my pretty friend you know what I mean
that she got kind of you know and I it's
weird I felt like our Dynamics sort of
like changed after that yeah because I I
don't know but yeah yeah I'm trying to
not get in trouble yeah I don't know
yeah no I understand I don't need
another 10 videos made about me the
thing that I think is interesting is is
I want to make a statement that it's not
good for you to have a super high BMI
it's difficult uh on your heart it's
difficult on your health it's difficult
on your joints yeah if I make that
statement that it's unhealthy to be at
that weight yeah that does not make me a
misogynist that does not make me a fat
shamer I'm making a statement and I can
show you thank you evidence to base what
I'm saying I also don't hate you because
I made that statement okay now uh you
know Nicole Arbor you remember when she
said dear fat people have you ever seen
that video she made I I've heard of it
yeah so Nicole Nicole Nicole got sick of
La just moved to [__] Nashville
because she was tired of yeah dealing
with all this [__] uh Nicole makes that
video now she's being a little bit more
satirical and she attacks some people a
little bit and and at the end she's like
Hey fat people I love you that's why I'm
saying this yeah but it goes back to
what we said before when I when I talked
to the girls who did only fans and I
didn't say I hate you I didn't call you
a name I just said here is a possible
consequence for your behavior then I was
called a misogynist right when I go off
and you say something the effective it
is not a good idea for you to weigh this
much we haven't gotten into the
Attraction part yeah I'm that doesn't
make me a pig for saying that it's
probably not a good idea for you to
weigh this much but what makes it even
more Insidious is this [__] here so the
37 culture study done in 1989 by Dr
David Buss where he looks at these 39
cultures they have nothing to do with
each other people from Papaya New Guinea
Yama Mama Indians people from who live
in the Andes they have no radio
television or film and they looked for a
small a perf a certain hip to waist
ratio about 0.72 yeah hip to waist ratio
in all of these cultures they look for
signs of Youth and signs of fertility
which means that
uh beauty is not subjective it's
actually objective you can actually see
there was this one study they've done
they've done it several times before
they do like a psychology 101 course and
they take everyone's picture they
superimpose them all over each other and
they get the average of all the faces
and that face is more attractive than
anyone in the course does that make
sense because it's a symmetrical face
so we know from that that beauty is
subjective and beauty is the
subjectivity of I'm sorry beauty is
objective and the objectivity of beauty
is implanted in US based on our genetics
that's why when you have the discussion
about whether or not men prefer very
obese women versus very skinny women
this is not the argument I always hear
is like no cultures telling me to not
accept women for being overweight and my
response to that is no here is
unassailable proof of this study of 37
cultures that proves that's not the case
and there's also studies where they show
like children stare at more attractive
faces for longer which means this is
hardwired into our genetics my
heterosexuality and my belief in like
what I find attractive is not a cultural
construct it is genetic that is
offensive to a lot of people the idea of
that whole thing happening that beauty
is objective and not subjective well and
the other thing that we were talking
about in the podcast she got mad about
was how like husbands are afraid to like
say this to their wives that they want
them to lose weight and I just don't
think that's fair like I I really don't
think it's fair and you know what else I
realized through this whole thing I'm
like people really it doesn't matter
like what you do for someone it's like
if they feel spotted like they're very
like there's no loyalty in a way uh like
that girl like literally we'd let her
stay with us in the Summers wow like for
free I'm like you know yeah she could
still have that opinion and then not
make tick tocks on it that's what I
thought yeah or keep it between you and
the other person yeah yeah so
um you know what's funny we you know
talk about different aspects of
masculinity one of the aspects that
doesn't get brought up enough is the
concept of like standing behind your
tribe even when they're wrong right yeah
so I agree like with the roller with the
whole tweet with the mat with the
vasectomy thing all these people start
attacking him and I'm like my first
instance you know Kevin Garnet obviously
yeah Kevin Garnett does this one
interview and he says if one of my
teammates gets into a fight I'm jumping
in on his side yeah I don't know what
the fight's over but you put your hands
on my teammate we're [__] going down
yeah when we get into the locker room
privately I'm gonna ask you okay bro
what happened why did we get into a
fight right when they go after Rolo
Rolo's my friend even if I don't agree
with everything he said like I think
he's too hard on you even if I don't
agree with everything Rolo says he's
still my friend I was gonna defend him
no matter what then when he we talk
about it's like oh I actually agree with
you this is stupid obviously he didn't
actually mean vasectomy he was just
saying this to be hyperbolic and it's
one of those situations where we uh
another example uh the guys I understood
the Tweet yeah I agreed with him like
with hello like um I mean I don't I
understood what he was saying he was
talking about it's the fastest way the
fastest the quickest way yeah and the
only foolproof way really is a vasectomy
like yeah I'm not saying do it but I
understood it was the 10 out of 10. like
10 out of 10 idiot proof way of doing it
that's what he was saying yeah and I
understood like so I was like I'm on
your side but it's okay yeah people
people just like took it out of context
yeah we had a long debate about it yeah
the thing is in the end he won because
like Ben Shapiro's not talking about me
right now she's not talking about me
correct yeah yeah in the end he did win
yeah
um so but I thought it was interesting
when men stand up for their friends or
for their tribe and then in this case
you have a woman who was part of your
tribe and she doesn't she just sells you
up the [__] River I think it's
masculine to stand behind your friends
even when they're wrong but then to
privately let them know hey bro this is
what we should be doing different and I
and what I'm seeing instead though is a
lot of very unmasculine men going off
and selling out their friends snitching
on their friends trying to steal your
girlfriend behind your back that seems
to be more of the case one of the funny
things that happens to me is because we
said before I have a ton of female
friends well my guy friends go to my
female friends and they start running
their mouth about me I find out about it
immediately I'm like bro you're a snitch
you understand what I'm saying that's so
true guys run they'll run their mouth
like I the amount of information I'm
like George Tennant bro I got so much
CIA information and they don't realize
that because they run their mouth to
these girls and they think the girls are
going to be loyal to them and that's not
the way it works right when you're not
loyal as a dude to me that's like worse
than anything that's why I never you'll
never even people that I don't like you
won't hear me talking bad about them
behind their back because this passive
aggression you know you know that
happened to me with the co-host right
like I had a CO oh I had a co-host that
like came out and said I was a colonizer
yeah you didn't hear about that yeah
specifically like colonizer like the
Imperial appearance I guess okay yeah I
guess you know blessings here against
his Free Will apparently well right yeah
that's funny no but it's yeah it's crazy
it's crazy the social media just like
changes social dynamics because there's
like money and throwing people under the
bus correct so that's so yeah my point
is it's not feminine but it's
non-masculine to throw your friends yes
that's like it's masculine to go to jail
for your homie and not snitch that is
masculine that is the reason why it's
masculine is because your ancestors were
willing to die for the tribe that is
masculinity the ultimate form of
masculinity is willing to die for your
tribe right okay the ultimate form of
not I'm not gonna call femininity I'm
call it non-masculinity the ultimate
form of non-masculinity is willing to
snitch on your homies steal his girl
does that make sense yeah because I'm
thinking like that's how do they get to
the men they would always like like
bring a woman and you know I mean and
like like have the girl sleep yeah
that's what happened with um Petraeus
General Petraeus was the head of the CIA
and he had to step down because he was
cheating on his wife with a reporter
well once like if foreign service
agencies this is our genius I'm sorry
yeah once foreign service agencies find
out that you're cheating on your wife
they can use it to Blackmail you sound
like a nine yeah as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible